[Musique]
te plaît tu peux sortir avec moi le
déguisement c'est à une façon de faire
la fête parce qu'il n'existe plus rien
il ya plus de pub docteur justement
parce que je sais qu'ils se trompent pas
et si vous êtes malade
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
bien que si à gauche
il aime ça on est un petit plus tard il
peut être qu'une chatte avoir deux
jambes de bois risque de ce désordre ou
équivalent à faire
[Rires]
[Musique]
les caisses que celle des tic du départ
du carnaval
c'est ce fameux le snuff cif pensé quoi
oui je suis donc à la danse et la
musique et la musique les tambours les
films ont capturé comme là je t'oublie
danse
les danses précis viennent on à avoir
ils sont je vous laisse obligés de
démarrer quand on entend cette musique
en suisse est lui qu on est obligé d'y
aller on
[Musique]
m
aujourd'hui vous vous sentez vraiment
différent oh c'est la force et la
journée du terme ça c'est pourri ça fait
longtemps vous l'attendiez rendent à
chapet 363 saloum fini la perruque et la
casquette au nom l'atlas est qu'on est
content de retrouver ces décès
[Musique]
vous avez encore des trace de rouge à
lèvres attention ah oui du projet revoir
alors vous avez fini commence carnaval
bon comme d'habitude bien quoi alors
jean comment est la voix ce matin
bah c'est mal il ya comme on dit à
dunkerque des kops pelle sur les cordes
vocales écopé de peines et des toiles
d'araignées c'est fini carnaval ah non
absolument pas à ça ne fait que
commencer
le fait de commencer c'est à dire c'est
à dire que demain il ya la bande de
rosendaël et demain après midi
et puis dimanche prochain la bande de
malo ne pas pouvoir chanter là en me si
ça sera avait établi pour demain on
soigne énergiquement 1
docteur ça fait combien vous êtes ait un
aspect deux heures maintenant c'est le
gros problème de la nuit il rentre à 4h
et commencer à se démaquiller ça c'est
un gros problème ce qu'il faut quand
même être présentable lendemain vous
étiez le malade de la bavure et où il va
mal au carmel carmes et la voix
légèrement cassée c'est le défoulement
beau blaise est la soupape de sûreté
galashiels savoir où on va toujours mal
on a une petite recette qui finalement
va faire plaisir à nos aînés alors plus
de peru puis de maquillage
tout ça est parti mais rangé
soigneusement est en place pour demain
matin demain après midi
parce que ça repart noire remet ça au
macho pour combien de temps hoballah
nous théoriquement les partis pour un
mois
pas trop fatiguer un peu quand même
[Musique]